ah yes dude when I flew home I [ __ ]
you know I play Wordle right like I kill
it at Wordle I got like 96 on world I've
only not and gotten it one time and it's
crazy but like not many people know that
because I don't sign in and share it
because I'm not about that [ __ ]
bragging life but I'm very good at
Wordle and so uh the guy next to me I
look over and he's playing Wordle and I
had already done Wordle and the Word was
mummy but he had no idea obviously and
he's trying to work it out and the first
word he checked was M something so he
had the m and then he got the MU and
then he got the m u and then nothing and
nothing and why and he had two guesses
left dude and he tried Mugsy which was
wrong because it was mummy and then he
had two guesses left and dude the guy
tried to write the word moxie
with two x's
tried it twice
and it shook because it's not a word and
tried it again like the thing was wrong
and I was like if this guy doesn't get
mummy dude and then he was like
m-u-m-p-w and I'm just like dude
and that was when I realized
he [ __ ]
was sniffing
and
dude
the guy next to me was sniffing so much
during the flight and thank God I only
realized it two hours left in the flight
because the flight was four hours and 30
minutes if I had noticed it before then
I I I would have snapped dude there were
two times where I was almost like hey
man you gotta blow your nose huh
oh what's up dude just plug it up right
oh but just plug it up though yeah
that like it's bad enough you can't get
mummy but you're gonna be sniffing every
[ __ ] dude I'm telling you it started
three to six times a minute by the end
of the flight it was I'm not joking 12
times a [ __ ] minute dude when he
every time he would just go it was a
lightning and I'm like even the CBD
can't cure that a lightning rod I think
it was the mummy thing and then with
that the lightning rod of anger dude
I'll just blow it I'll just blow it
and I [ __ ] let me see if I could find
these texts because bro it was so
[ __ ] funny man
it was so funny because I was like I I
had to get I had to
vent because I didn't want dude you know
why I'm good I'm good because of this
and I'm going to tell you why I'm good
and you're going to listen I'm going to
tell you why I'm good okay because
um I would I was telling I was so mad oh
God I really gotta chill
but I was so
mad and
um
now here we go here we go that I was
like let me touch the chain group chain
about it because you know I get [ __ ]
Wi-Fi because no I get them you know I
get Wi-Fi on the floor it costs [ __ ]
29 bucks but [ __ ] no deadly so
um
I I so I texted my friends
this is this is actually so this is what
got so funny I didn't realize how funny
it was gonna be but [ __ ] my anger was
subsiding and I found a way to exercise
it in a different way and I I and then I
just sparked a joy in myself so you can
get through anything really if you put
your mind to it but I wrote to the guys
my God this guy next to me is sniffing
three to six times a minute it's driving
me mental and it doesn't even seem like
he needs to that was the other thing too
it wasn't like he was going and it was
juicy like okay I get it he's sick but
he wasn't sick dude he was just sniffing
and I know you're probably like well
maybe he had a tick but he didn't do it
he didn't and I'm not a doctor but I
know it wasn't a tick because the guy
was so regular and he just kept checking
ESPN and watching a [ __ ] movie with
Sean hatties so I was like dude he
doesn't have a tick
I don't know what the movie was do I
couldn't figure it out but I look at
people's phones when I'm next to them I
I know you could probably tell that by
now but
um so I write and so then I I let it go
and then I write now it's like 12 times
a minute I'm dude I'm going crazy I'm
afraid I'll snap at him I wrote him I
wrote the text chain that because I
didn't want to snap at him right
and then somebody said hey I'm a a
little tissue and I said yeah like
[ __ ] blow it
and I said I know it's about two hours
ago I said not sure if it was the whole
flight but it had to have gotten worse
um
and then I wrote Oh My and then I wrote
I'm going to text one every time he does
it so you know okay
and I write one one my buddy writes I'm
dying I write one my buddy writes haha
nice Jesus I write one one he says it's
too long a flight to not ask him I write
one one he says is this first class I
say yeah even though I shouldn't ask
that because he knows then I wrote one
he said yeah you got to say something
and and then and then [ __ ] my friend
my average friend is like oh you're
still flying this late I said Mark yeah
you know this isn't about that like
stick with the program also like what
what I'm what do you I'm saying one I'm
next to the guys like what does he think
so again I write one because he sniffed
again
and he says world and then I just said
we're Landing one one and he says just
slap him as you land and I write and I
write one and he says you should make a
noise every time he does it now that is
a great gangster move dude
if he just and I go oh
oh oh oh
like that's gangster but it was too late
and we were Landing
um
one and then could you imagine sitting
next to this one
he says earful my friend says earphones
maybe I said I have them dude he was
breaking through this here's the other
thing too I lost my
I lost my I bring two airpods airpods
are [ __ ] hey fall out of my pocket
more make them rounder
you know first of all make them so they
don't fall out of your pockets they want
you to they want you to see I told you
I've been ahead of I've been in
conspiracy before this is Apple the
Apple products this is they want you to
fall they want to follow your pockets
because so that's why they make them all
sleek and [ __ ] and round so you get to
buy new ones and guess what I do to beat
Apple at their own game when my [ __ ]
head when my airpods fall out of my
pocket
I don't even try to look for him I lost
them I try a little bit I go where is it
I duck in the airplane I go under the
seat of the airplane guess what dude
they're gone they're gone I don't let
Apple get the best of me they don't make
me that angry plus I'm using all my
anger for the sniffer right so I I just
go into my
backpack I take out other airpods and I
you know what that is game tax when you
lose your Apple products that's game tax
when the [ __ ] airpods fall out game
tax dude and of course I want I I wear
the [ __ ] Slide the side pockets so
it's easier to fall out but that's
fashion dude I don't want I don't want
the pockets on the like the Jean pockets
are you guys with me on this you know
what I mean if you're listening let me
know in the comments but anyway so I
took out my other ones and I didn't have
the noise canceling on these so I'm like
I have the earphones and I still heard
the [ __ ] so I write one okay [ __ ] man
one I'm going nuts gotta land
then I'm like
then they say
uh record him and I'm like what a great
[ __ ] idea
so I'm like I'm gonna record this dude
and all I have to do is
put my head near his head
because I got the airpods in right I
don't have to put the phone over near
his head I have to because I was like oh
that's gonna be obvious but then I'm
like I just lean over
and he was watching this [ __ ] Sean
hatties movie and I'm just leaning over
with my earphones and I'm and I'm
hitting the record button
and he's doing it so much that I get him
so here is him sniffing
here here's him sniffing
okay you heard it it's okay so you heard
it dude all right now that's not that
loud but it's too loud period if you
could hear it on my airpods okay so he's
dude the extra time in the beginning you
know here
there it is dude all right now that's
too loud okay uh so I write you can hear
at the end I'm dying that's him not me
so then I said oh insane whoa he just
did a big one wanna hear another and
they say yeah and another guy says 100
and I go
there you go
that's me saying you're looking
all right cool so I wanted him to hear
me say that a little bit
my buddy says oh man this is hilarious
this is a loud one I got him again
this is so funny
look the flight attendants
it's a long build up but it's good the
payoff is excellent
here we go here we go it's coming up
foreign
unbelievable dude that is so loud
I caught one in the beginning and then
this is I got two on this one
this is the [ __ ] I do man I'm 42. but
this is okay so there's a little one in
the beginning it's really way in the
beginning and then there's one at the
end here
there
oh you heard that one there you go
here comes another one
let's wait for another
there it is dude so annoying bro when
you realize that dude it's like water
torture you heard it right
um I I said wow I'm fuming thank God
this is fun now okay and then
I did
something that was that they don't know
and they don't listen to this podcast so
they're not gonna know but do it
I did something so I could have so much
fun
and and and I I did a Sniff and I did it
really loud and I said oh my God he
looked at me after this one and it was
so big
okay that's me
[Laughter]
but the other ones were his and I said
let me get real close I hope he doesn't
catch me and they said oh he looked at
me
bro they thought it was him right here
look how loud
dude think about me just in my thing in
my like seat like doing this you know
I'll do it like also like people on the
flight some of the people knew who I was
and like Chris I'm just like crystally
is just sitting there recording him so
I'm gonna go
and like laughing afterwards
wow dude I love doing [ __ ] I love being
a [ __ ] dumb idiot dude life rips I
love it dude
I love it man
they still think it's him don't tell him
don't tell those guys
um
God I love it
so yeah so that's what's up that's what
was the flight wow we talk about the
[ __ ] hard-hitting issues here at this
podcast
[Music]
[Music]